that crash is just one of the many that
has law enforcement concerned as jeremy
j ford reports police across the valley
are targeting speeders and those not
obeying the basic rules of the road
law enforcement in north las vegas are
stepping up their patrolling the goal to
stop accidents from happening like this
in an effort to keep the streets safer
it's good if they respect
the people that are doing the right
thing as part of a speeding enforcement
campaign that started monday police aim
to increase law enforcement
participation by coordinating highly
visible patrols across the state
sylvia fowler says she didn't know an
increased police presence was needed in
the area because to her it's not that
bad i've seen a few accidents you know
and
once in a while somebody speeding or
something law enforcement will be
looking for speeding and collision
causing violations providing safety
about slowing down and the significance
of slower speeds on roadways a plus for
good drivers says angel gomez who
welcomes these safety measures
so you've got to be careful take care of
our kids pretty much that's it man
jeremy j ford live local now